Jake: 还没解封
Jake: The lockdown hadn't lifted.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 所以就是我当时被相当于封在上海
Lucia: So I was basically stuck in Shanghai.
Lucia: 去不了别的地方一段时间
Lucia: Couldn't go anywhere else for a while.
Lucia: 然后这段时间在上海找了一个舞室
Lucia: 然后就是那会是吧
Lucia: And then, you know...
Jake: 是是在一个小区还是
Jake: Was it in a residential area or...
Lucia: 本来本来想学一下
Lucia: Originally, I wanted to learn...
Jake: 不是小区不能出
Jake: Couldn't leave the residential area?
Lucia: 是小区就是他
Lucia: It was in a residential area...
Lucia: 是舞房的话
Lucia: 一般他都购物中心里面
Lucia: Usually, they're in shopping centers.
Jake: 哦这样子OK
Jake: Oh, I see. OK.
Lucia: 然后就是我
Lucia: So, I...
Lucia: 我本来想去试一下学那个
Lucia: Originally wanted to try learning...
Lucia: 我当时报了一个swag还是breaking的课
Lucia: I signed up for a swag or breaking class at the time.
Jake: 哎呀你这也没电了
Jake: Oh no, your battery is dying.
Lucia: 然后跳了两三节之后我发现不行
Lucia: After two or three sessions, I realized it wasn't working.
Lucia: 我跳不动
Lucia: I couldn't dance.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 然后我就放弃了
Lucia: So, I gave up.
Katrina:  我们我报的那个hip Hop班
Katrina: I signed up for a hip-hop class.
Katrina:  我是报通卡
Katrina: I signed up for an unlimited pass.
Katrina:  就是什么班都能跳
Katrina: So, I could attend any class.
Katrina:  然后他这黑怕
Katrina: And then there's this hip-hop...
Katrina:  他是基本不教那种片段舞
Katrina: He basically doesn't teach those dance segments.
Jake: 你这个是没电了
Jake: Yours is out of battery.
Katrina:  就是只练基本功
Katrina: Just practices basic skills.
Lucia: 那那很好
Lucia: Well, that's good.
Katrina:  对有一点点但是会有一点点枯燥
Katrina: Yeah, a bit, but it gets a bit dull.
Lucia: 对有一点点
Lucia: Yeah, a little bit.
Katrina:  然后像爵士这种
Katrina: And like jazz...
Alice: 线的宝
Alice: The cable is precious.
Jake: 没电了就是单纯的没电插上
Jake: It's just out of battery, plug it in.
Lucia: 但是我觉得很好看
Lucia: But I think it's beautiful.
Lucia: 但是我感觉我自己好像不是很漂亮
Lucia: But I feel like I'm not very pretty.
Katrina:  但是你你学
Katrina: But you, you learn.
Tasha: 有电了吗
Tasha: Is it charged?
Katrina:  还挺顺的
Katrina: It's going quite smoothly.
Jake: 没有你要setup一下
Jake: No, you need to set it up.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 哦yes好
Jake: Oh yes, good.
Tasha: blue 蓝牙连接失败
Tasha: Blue, Bluetooth connection failed.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Alice: 按个什么
Alice: Press what?
Alice: 看看你的视频
Alice: Let's watch your video.
Katrina:  就我一个同学找工作呢
Katrina: So, a classmate of mine is looking for a job.
Katrina:  他他一个offer在长沙一个在苏州
Katrina: He, he has one offer in Changsha and another in Suzhou.
Katrina:  他在纠结去哪
Katrina: He's torn about where to go.
Jake: 消费也不一样
Jake: The cost of living is different too.
Alice: 妈呀看不懂
Alice: Gosh, I can't understand.
Katrina:  对苏州那是要比长沙
Katrina: Yeah, Suzhou is more expensive than Changsha.
Katrina:  他你知道他今年考研
Katrina: You know, he's taking the graduate exam this year.
Katrina:  他他出了分数以后
Katrina: After he got his scores...
Alice: 这么多人都在看
Alice: So many people are watching.
Katrina:  他觉得自己文考不上你知道吗
Katrina: He thought he wouldn't pass, you know?
Katrina:  结果
Katrina: But...
Katrina:  今年统计的分数比去年低了三四十分
Katrina: This year's scores are thirty or forty points lower than last year.
Lucia: 然后他考上了
Lucia: And then he passed.
Katrina:  他其实考上了
Katrina: He actually passed.
Katrina:  但是他没有准备一点的复试
Katrina: But he didn't prepare for the interview at all.
Katrina:  他直接找工作去了
Katrina: He just went straight to finding a job.
Katrina:  我靠今年真的很奇怪
Katrina: Honestly, this year is really strange.
Jake: 那他后来准备了吗
Jake: So did he prepare later?
Katrina:  没准备复试
Katrina: Didn't prepare for the retest.
Katrina:  他直接没去复试他就找工作去了
Katrina: He didn't even go for the retest, he just went to find a job.
Katrina:  有点烦
Katrina: It's a bit annoying.
Lucia: 有点可惜
Lucia: It's kind of a pity.
Lucia: 他应该就是
Lucia: He should have just...
Lucia: 反正已经拿到复试机会了
Lucia: Anyway, he already got the retest opportunity.
Jake: 对啊准备个一天吗
Jake: Yeah, just prepare for a day, right?
Lucia: 就是跑的不太理想
Lucia: But he didn't run very well.
Katrina:  但是但是他他出那个对好像同济
Katrina: But, but he, he went to Tongji University.
Jake: 对啊是哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, right, hahaha.
Lucia: 说不定就是我了
Lucia: Maybe it was me.
Jake: 对啊卡拉OK
Jake: Yeah, karaoke.
Jake: 对一会修硕就卡拉OK回来了
Jake: Yeah, Shure will be back from karaoke soon.
Katrina:  同济还不怎么删人呢
Katrina: Tongji University doesn't usually eliminate people.
Lucia: 咳
Lucia: Cough.
Jake: 哈哈重新开了
Jake: Haha, it's started again.
Tasha: 我重新开了要读秒吗
Tasha: I restarted it, should we count down?
Jake: 要要
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice: 我们今天是不是还没读秒
Alice: Didn't we count down today?
Tasha: 没读
Tasha: No, we didn't.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  哦还有风花
Katrina: Oh, there's still wind and flowers.
Katrina:  特别是这种有花苞的可以记录一下
Katrina: Especially those with buds, we can note them down.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come.
Jake: 看时间
Jake: Look at the time.
Katrina: 喜欢打游戏
Katrina: Likes playing games.
Katrina: 看游戏吗
Katrina: Watching games?
Katrina: 看比赛我有个舍友天天看
Katrina: Watching matches, I have a roommate who watches them every day.
Tasha: 真的吗对
Tasha: Really, right?
Katrina:  对他
Katrina: Yes, he...
Katrina:  他会因为那些选手没打好而气得半死
Katrina: He gets so mad when the players don't perform well.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  这这他在宿舍又哭又笑的
Katrina: He laughs and cries in the dorm.
Tasha: 又哭又笑的
Tasha: Laughs and cries.
Katrina:  看总决赛的时候他看的
Katrina: During the finals, he was watching...
Tasha: 哦他看的难道是LCK决赛
Tasha: Oh, was he watching the LCK finals?
Jake: 啊哈这么带劲
Jake: Ah, so exciting.
Katrina:  难道是他就看英雄联盟
Katrina: Maybe, he only watches League of Legends.
Tasha: 还是LPL吗
Tasha: Or was it the LPL?
Katrina:  我不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina:  他看好多
Katrina: He watches a lot.
Katrina:  对LPL他他都看
Katrina: Yeah, he watches all the LPL games.
Alice: 你最喜欢谁啊
Alice: Who's your favorite?
Alice: 我最喜欢的就是
Alice: My favorite is...
Tasha: 我最喜欢的就是这支队伍的这个选手
Tasha: My favorite is this player from this team.
Alice: 这叫啥
Alice: What's his name?
Tasha: 他叫Cherry
Tasha: His name is Cherry.
Katrina:  他看他喜欢
Katrina: He watches him, likes him.
Katrina:  那叫什么小花生
Katrina: What's his name, Peanut?
Katrina:  韩国的那个
Katrina: The Korean one.
Tasha: enough
Tasha: Enough.
Alice: not
Alice: Not.
Katrina:  他叫他对对对
Katrina: He's called... yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  好像是他
Katrina: Seems like it's him.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我知道
Tasha: Haha, I know.
Katrina:  就是那个单眼皮那个他
Katrina: It's that single-eyelid guy, him.
Tasha: 特别帅的打野
Tasha: The really handsome jungler.
Katrina:  他就说他长得挺帅的
Katrina: He said he's pretty handsome.
Tasha: Tina和我喜欢的Chovy
Tasha: Tina and I like Chovy.
Tasha: 昨去年是一支队伍的
Tasha: Last year they were on the same team.
Tasha: 然后今年他们全部都转队了
Tasha: And this year, they've all switched teams.
Alice: 我好像看到过很多次这个名字
Alice: I think I've seen that name a lot.
Tasha: Faker
Tasha: Faker.
Alice: 嗯看什么顶级的
Alice: Yeah, he watches the top-tier ones.
Tasha: 他是什么
Tasha: What is he?
Katrina:  啊我也是
Katrina: Ah, me too.
Tasha: 顶级的什么
Tasha: Top-tier what?
Katrina:  Faker不是那个最有名的
Katrina: Isn't Faker the most famous one?
Tasha: 他就是嗯
Tasha: He is, yeah.
Tasha: 打野吗顶级重男
Tasha: A jungler? Top-tier heavy...
Tasha: 他怎么说呢
Tasha: How should I say...
Tasha: 他特别厉害
Tasha: He's really amazing.
Tasha: 怎么说他现在就是已经30岁了
Tasha: How should I say, he's already 30 years old now.
Tasha: 一般选手在25岁就要退役了
Tasha: Most players retire by 25.
Tasha: 就是因为反应速度跟不上
Tasha: Because they can't keep up with the reaction speed.
Tasha: 然后他在30岁这年
Tasha: And at 30 years old,
Tasha: 还拿了一个世界总冠军
Tasha: He won a world championship.
Tasha: 哇哦对
Tasha: Wow, yeah.
Tasha: 然后他人身上已经拿过三次冠军
Tasha: And he's already won the championship three times.
Tasha: 这是第四次冠军
Tasha: This is his fourth championship.
Tasha: 很多人打了十年都没有过一次冠军
Tasha: A lot of people have played for ten years without winning a single championship.
Katrina: 好厉害对
Katrina: That's amazing, right?
Tasha: 对而且他是出道级巅峰吧
Tasha: Yeah, and he was at his peak when he debuted.
Tasha: 好像是15岁
Tasha: I think he was 15 years old.
Tasha: 然后高中
Tasha: Then in high school.
Tasha: 上初中还是上高中
Tasha: Was it middle school or high school?
Tasha: 的时候偶然间被发现了
Tasha: He was accidentally discovered.
Tasha: 然后就然后就被选中了
Tasha: And then he got selected.
Tasha: 然后就打比赛
Tasha: Then he started competing.
Tasha: 然后一打比赛
Tasha: And in his first match,
Tasha: 就把当时的顶级中单
Tasha: he one-on-one defeated the top mid-laner at the time.
Tasha: 给一对一的杀掉了
Tasha: Just killed him one-on-one.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's incredible.
Tasha: 然后就一战成名
Tasha: And he became famous overnight.
Jake: 好过分啊
Jake: That's so unfair.
Jake: 哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 对
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 强到过分
Jake: He's ridiculously strong.
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Tasha: 就是一出道就强盗过分
Tasha: He was just insanely strong from the start.
Tasha: 并且一直强了这么多年
Tasha: And he's stayed that strong for so many years.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  昨天那个写名字的
Katrina: The one who wrote his name yesterday.
Tasha: 而且他就是从来不买皮肤
Tasha: And he never buys skins.
Tasha: 就是不提倡大家买皮肤
Tasha: He doesn't encourage people to buy skins.
Tasha: 所以他在比赛还是平时的打
Tasha: So whether it's in competitions or regular play,
Tasha: 打游戏就只用原皮
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈好有意思
Alice: Hahahaha, that's so interesting.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina:  我纯技术虐
Katrina: I purely rely on skill.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 好像说韩国90%的人只要玩英雄联盟
Tasha: They say 90% of people in Korea who play League of Legends
Tasha: 都是他的粉丝
Tasha: are his fans.
Jake: 剩下10%嫉妒他是吗呵
Jake: The remaining 10% are jealous of him, right?
Tasha: 男粉啊什么男生嫉妒他
Tasha: Male fans, guys are jealous of him.
Tasha: 女生都很喜欢他
Tasha: Girls all really like him.
Tasha: 而且保持着极高的职业素养
Tasha: And he maintains a very high level of professionalism.
Tasha: 到现在都没有谈过一场恋爱
Tasha: He hasn't had a single relationship until now.
Tasha: 哇为就是为游戏奉献人生的感觉
Tasha: Wow, it feels like dedicating your life to the game.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Tasha: 就
Tasha: Just...
Tasha: 尽管他们这支队伍现在就是比较差
Tasha: Even though their team is pretty bad right now.
Tasha: 之前一段时间Faker他因为手受伤
Tasha: There was a time when Faker was injured.
Tasha: 他就暂时没有参加比赛
Tasha: So he didn't participate in the matches for a while.
Tasha: 然后他们队连最弱的队伍都没有打过
Tasha: And their team couldn't even beat the weakest team.
Tasha: 就是十连败
Tasha: They had ten consecutive losses.
Alice: 哈哈十连败
Alice: Haha, ten consecutive losses.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后现在飞快
Tasha: Hahaha, but now he's back.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 一上场就直接打总
Tasha: As soon as he's back, they go straight to the finals.
Katrina: carry全场
Katrina: He carries the whole game.
Tasha: 就直接打总决赛了都
Tasha: They go straight to the finals.
Tasha: 他可能是队伍的一个核心大脑
Tasha: He might be the brain of the team.
Tasha: 就那种偏指挥的
Tasha: The one who commands and strategizes.
Tasha: 还有偏运营的都归他啊
Tasha: He handles the operations and everything else.
Alice: 他长哪个样子
Alice: What does he look like?
Tasha: 这是他们队的ad
Tasha: This is their AD player.
Tasha: 因为现在在选ad位
Tasha: Because now they're choosing an AD position.
Tasha: 这个人长得是不是有点像杨戬
Tasha: Doesn't this guy look a bit like Erlang Shen?
Tasha: 哈哈哈我当时看的时候
Tasha: Hahaha, when I saw him...
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Katrina:  你写一下名字
Katrina: Write down the name.
Tasha: 就是那个宝莲灯里面的那个三眼狼
Tasha: Like the three-eyed wolf in the Lotus Lantern.
Katrina:  这选花吗
Katrina: Is this person choosing the flower?
Alice: 你写吧还是你写
Alice: You write it, or I will.
Alice: 你写啥
Alice: What are you writing?
Tasha: 给我画个翅膀就行
Tasha: Just draw me some wings.
Alice: 天呐我的翅膀多丑
Alice: Oh my god, my wings are so ugly.
Tasha: 那个peanut
Tasha: That peanut...
Alice: nice
Alice: Nice.
Tasha: 给你们看看LCK美男
Tasha: Let me show you the handsome men of LCK.
Katrina:  要给他们晒太
Katrina: We have to show them off.
Alice: 办
Alice: Let's do it.
Katrina:  们稍微挑一下
Katrina: Let's choose a bit.
Alice: 怎么办就这样吧哈哈哈
Alice: What to do, let's just do it like this, haha.
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's just do it.
Tasha: 这个就是peanut
Tasha: This is peanut.
Alice: 给你加个爱心好了
Alice: I'll add a heart for you.
Tasha: 就是那个小花生
Tasha: It's that little peanut.
Katrina:  看看我看看是不是他
Katrina: Let me see if it's him.
Katrina:  抖音经常发的那个男人
Katrina: The guy who posts often on Douyin.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina:  是他我知道
Katrina: It's him, I know.
Tasha: 我知道
Tasha: I know.
Alice: 我知道
Alice: I know.
Tasha: 很帅啦
Tasha: He's very handsome.
Alice: 很帅吧
Alice: Really handsome, right?
Katrina:  我给你看他的抖音
Katrina: I'll show you his Douyin.
Katrina:  他每天都发这些的
Katrina: He posts these every day.
Alice: 真的很帅的
Alice: He's really handsome.
Tasha: 真的很帅的
Tasha: He's really handsome.
Katrina:  他是是挺帅的
Katrina: Yeah, he's pretty handsome.
Tasha: 嗯是呃
Tasha: Hmm, yes.
Tasha: 这种辅助型大业的代表了啊
Tasha: He's the representative of supportive heroes.
Tasha: 这个就是我喜欢的英雄
Tasha: This is the hero I like.
Jake: 这就是补刀不漏兵吗
Jake: Is this where you don't miss a single last hit?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 一刀不漏呵呵
Tasha: Not missing a single hit, haha.
Jake: 呵
Jake: Heh.
Katrina:  他的抖音
Katrina: His Douyin.
Katrina:  每天剪他的
Katrina: He edits his videos every day.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 他真的很可爱了
Tasha: He's really cute.
Katrina:  哎对他就每天说
Katrina: Yeah, he says every day...
Katrina:  你知道他有多可爱吗
Katrina: Do you know how cute he is?
Katrina:  我说谁都给你看
Katrina: I tell everyone to watch him.
Tasha: 他谁啊好丑啊哈哈
Tasha: Who is he, he's so ugly, haha.
Tasha: 哎这个是国内选手
Tasha: Hey, this is a domestic player.
Lucia: 老师这是个混剪
Lucia: Teacher, this is a compilation.
Lucia: 我以为是他的个人丧呢
Lucia: I thought it was his personal video.
Tasha: 这个也是国内选手
Tasha: This is also a domestic player.
Alice: 为什么我感觉他又长得有点像那个谁
Alice: Why does he look a bit like that guy...
Tasha: 刘青松
Tasha: Liu Qingsong.
Alice: 刘青松不认识是那个
Alice: I don't know Liu Qingsong, it's that...
Alice: 王
Alice: Wang...
Tasha: 他已经算是
Tasha: He's already considered...
Tasha: 国内就中国队的第一美男了
Tasha: The most handsome guy in the Chinese team.
Alice: 刚刚那个长得好像那个
Alice: That person just now looked like...
Alice: 谁呀
Alice: Who was it?
Alice: 想不想我难受
Alice: Can't remember, it's bothering me.
Tasha: 我都不喜欢
Tasha: I don't like any of them.
Tasha: 都很一般哈哈哈
Tasha: They're all just so-so, hahaha.
Jake: 好开点外卖吧
Jake: Alright, let's order some takeout.
Jake: 点点外卖吧
Jake: Let's order some takeout.
Alice:王王什么王
Alice: Wang Wang what Wang?
Tasha: and我觉得
Tasha: and I think...
Alice: 王什么
Alice: Wang what?
Alice:王什么
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 点外卖还是
Katrina: Order takeout or...
Jake: 点外卖
Jake: Order takeout.
Katrina:  一下自己的花纹
Katrina: Check your own pattern.
Tasha: 这款围很喜欢
Tasha: I really like this scarf.
Jake: 挑花
Jake: Pick a pattern.
Jake: 要不等修硕来
Jake: Or wait for Shure to come.
Jake: 我们先把这一端给结了就结束吧
Jake: Let's finish this end first and then call it a day.
Jake: 上午上午
Jake: Morning, morning.
Alice: 点了是吗
Alice: Did you order it?
Jake: 就这样还没有点
Jake: Not yet, not yet.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: It's this one.
Jake: 关掉关掉关掉
Jake: Turn it off, turn it off.
Alice: 这就是把这个点掉
Alice: Just turn this off?
Katrina:  还有我们的舞蹈
Katrina: And our dance...
Tasha: 什么点掉这个
Tasha: What, turn this off?
Alice: 就关掉要开始关了是吗对
Alice: Just turn it off, are we starting to shut down? Yes.
Tasha: 关掉关掉干嘛好
Tasha: Turn it off, turn it off, okay.
Jake: 对关掉
Jake: Yes, turn it off.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Alice: 关掉结束了
Alice: Turn it off, it's over.
Tasha: 我在面对以后的
Tasha: I'm facing the future...
Katrina:  天呐感觉货到了那种
Katrina: Oh my, it feels like the delivery is here.
Tasha: 好没有什么下算了黑眼圈
Tasha: Okay, there's nothing, forget it, dark circles.
Jake: 第二步
Jake: Step two.
Lucia: 校准一下时间
Lucia: Let's calibrate the time.
Jake: 对第二部校准一下
Jake: Yes, step two, let's calibrate.
Alice: 你得给他看好这个
Alice: You have to show him this properly.
Tasha: 好这个
Tasha: Okay, this one.
Alice:我自己涂开吧嗯
Alice: I'll apply it myself then.
Lucia: 哎我又把我手机撂哪去了
Lucia: Hey, where did I put my phone again?
Alice:启动
Alice: Start.
Alice:我一想到这是个摄像头我就有点难受
Alice: The moment I think it's a camera, I feel a bit uncomfortable.
Tasha: 感觉这化妆刷也不是很好用
Tasha: Feels like this makeup brush isn't very good.
Tasha: 为什么卖十几块钱一个
Tasha: Why does it cost over ten bucks?
Tasha: 打底
Tasha: Foundation.
Alice:直接用手揉开就行了吧
Alice: Just use your hands to blend it, right?
Alice:这就是拇指
Alice: This is the thumb.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:自带讲解的
Alice: It comes with explanations.
Jake: 挺好挺好
Jake: Very good, very good.
Jake: 满分数据我去
Jake: Full marks, wow.
Alice:这是亚洲四大邪术之一
Alice: This is one of the four great Asian dark arts.
Tasha: 哦你稍微转过来一些
Tasha: Oh, turn a bit more this way.
Tasha: 其他几个是啥来着
Tasha: What are the other ones again?
Jake: 这是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 给你增加一些
Lucia: I'll add some for you.
Tasha: 我也不记得
Tasha: I don't remember either.
Lucia: 人类早期绘制猫咪的珍贵场面
Lucia: It's an early human depiction of a cat.
Jake: 哦临摹是吗
Jake: Oh, sketching, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈对
Lucia: Hahaha, yes.
Jake: 现在在
Jake: Now it's...
Alice:这叫面中提亮吗
Alice: Is this called highlighting the face center?
Tasha: 哦是吗
Tasha: Oh, is it?
Jake: 我去
Jake: Wow.
Alice:是我懂但我不会
Alice: Yes, I understand but I can't do it.
Jake: 有点专业的
Jake: It's kind of professional.
Tasha: 你有点专业在身上呢
Tasha: You're a bit professional yourself.
Alice:然后没了
Alice: And that's it.
Tasha: 但是我今天也没遮瑕
Tasha: But I didn't use concealer today either.
Tasha: 太麻烦了
Tasha: Too troublesome.
Tasha: 那倒不必了
Tasha: No need for that.
Tasha: 但是我也不知道怎么把他画的很甜
Tasha: But I also don't know how to make it look sweet.
Jake: 好多笔啊
Jake: So many pens!
Alice:我会一点点
Alice: I can do a little bit.
Jake: 我也在找笔
Jake: I'm also looking for a pen.
Tasha: 找什么笔
Tasha: What kind of pen are you looking for?
Jake: 你能写什么笔
Jake: What kind of pen can you write with?
Lucia: 哎刚才才那个那支笔
Lucia: Hey, just now that pen...
Lucia: 那个咱们用来写那个啥的画
Lucia: The one we used to draw that thing...
Jake: 是我自己
Jake: It's mine.
Jake: 有一只给我扔哪去了
Jake: I threw it somewhere.
Lucia: 不对我把这个爪子画太长了
Lucia: No, I made this claw too long.
Alice:这是干皮的还是油皮的
Alice: Is this for dry skin or oily skin?
Tasha: 干皮的
Tasha: It's for dry skin.
Tasha: 完事
Tasha: All done.
Alice:无所谓就这样吧
Alice: It doesn't matter, just leave it like that.
Tasha: 我总感觉我帮你画的不好看
Tasha: I always feel like I didn't make it look good for you.
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Tasha: 我的妈
Tasha: Oh my!
Alice:我每次都差不多用这种香
Alice: I almost always use this kind of fragrance.
Lucia: 哈对不起
Lucia: Haha, sorry.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 他有那个什么吗
Lucia: Does he have that thing?
Jake: 这这这
Jake: This, this, this.
Tasha: 感觉挤太多了
Tasha: Feels like too much was squeezed out.
Lucia: 啊啊sorry sorry
Lucia: Ah, ah, sorry, sorry.
Jake: 没事
Jake: It's okay.
Tasha: 哦我不了
Tasha: Oh, I won't.
Lucia: 要命
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia: 我今天已经掉了第二次充电宝了
Lucia: I've dropped my power bank for the second time today.
Tasha: 是挤的有点多
Tasha: Yeah, it's a bit too much.
Jake: 没关系劲摔
Jake: It's okay, it can handle it.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: No worries.
Alice:抹脖子
Alice: Rub it on your neck.
Jake: 抹脖子
Jake: Rub it on your neck.
Tasha: 吃的要来点吗
Tasha: Want some food?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 我哈哈哈
Jake: I, hahaha...
Jake: 啊抹哪
Jake: Huh, where to rub?
Alice:我脸上
Alice: On my face.
Lucia: 是化点妆吗
Lucia: Are you going to put on some makeup?
Lucia: 要哈哈
Lucia: Yes, haha.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 这化妆
Jake: This makeup...
Tasha: 眼镜摘下来吧
Tasha: Take off your glasses.
Lucia: 这个这个充电宝稍微有点大
Lucia: This power bank is a bit big.
Jake: 这么专业的
Jake: So professional.
Lucia: 我口袋里放不下
Lucia: It doesn't fit in my pocket.
Jake: 要不放椅子上啊
Jake: How about putting it on the chair?
Tasha: 啊粉扑帮您扑开
Tasha: Ah, let me help you spread the powder.
Lucia: 我可以把他用腿压住
Lucia: I can hold it down with my leg.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 然后说不要动
Tasha: Then don't move.
Tasha: 好美呀好美
Tasha: So beautiful, so beautiful.
Tasha: 不要动不要眨眼睛哈哈
Tasha: Don't move, don't blink, haha.
Alice:我总感觉没弄匀
Alice: I feel like it's not even.
Alice: 就这样还有点
Alice: It's still a bit...
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 杨老师你那胡子是不是该刮了
Tasha: Mr. Yang, don't you think it's time to shave your beard?
Jake: 嗯确实
Jake: Yes, indeed.
Alice:抹匀了吗
Alice: Is it even now?
Alice:匀了吧
Alice: It looks even, right?
Alice:美呀
Alice: Beautiful.
Tasha: 太美了杨老师
Tasha: So beautiful, Mr. Yang.
Alice: 太美了
Alice: So beautiful.
Jake: 是啊太美了
Jake: Yes, so beautiful.
Tasha: 太美了
Tasha: So beautiful.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha: 直接白了3个多
Tasha: Instantly three shades lighter.
Tasha: 您看一看
Tasha: Take a look.
Jake: 我看一看
Jake: Let me see.
Jake: 哈哈哈我去
Jake: Hahaha, oh my.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 啊太美了
Lucia: Ah, so beautiful.
Lucia: 哈哈哈肤质一下就变得特别好
Lucia: Hahaha, your skin looks so good now.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 不是不是以前也很好
Lucia: No, no, it was good before too.
Lucia: 就是更好了
Lucia: That's even better.
Jake: 这么回事可以
Jake: Is that so? Okay.
Tasha: 明了就这吧
Tasha: Alright, let's go with this.
Jake: 就是这就是什么
Jake: So, what is this?
Jake: 磨皮吗
Jake: Smoothing?
Tasha: 睫毛了已经
Tasha: It's already the eyelashes.
Tasha: 腮红吧
Tasha: Blush, maybe?
Alice:啊最后再腮红啊
Alice: Ah, blush at the end?
Tasha: 啊啊行
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Alice: 啊行眼睫毛
Alice: Ah, alright, eyelashes.
Tasha: 我们是不是用的同款
Tasha: Are we using the same one?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 擦了一下之后好不对称
Lucia: After wiping it, it's really asymmetrical.
Tasha: 你要贴假睫毛吗
Tasha: Do you want to put on fake eyelashes?
Tasha: 好你要用我的吗
Tasha: Okay, do you want to use mine?
Jake: 我们是不是有买笔这个环节
Jake: Do we have a segment where we bought pens?
Jake: 买这个白板笔
Jake: Buying these whiteboard markers.
Lucia: 白板笔有这个环节吗
Lucia: Do we have a segment for whiteboard markers?
Jake: 我怎么记得昨天有这个
Jake: I remember we had this yesterday.
Jake: 没有就算了
Jake: If not, never mind.
Jake: 呵呵没有也可以买
Jake: Haha, we can buy them anyway.
Lucia: 打孔器和彩笔
Lucia: A hole puncher and colored pens.
Lucia: 哎确实有
Lucia: Ah, we do have them.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 但是已经有人在这里打了个勾
Lucia: But someone already checked it off.
Lucia: 我不知道是不是
Lucia: I don't know if it's...
Jake: 好行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn.
Alice:那我用了给你推荐一下
Alice: I'll try it and recommend it to you.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 哦就挤在这啊
Tasha: Oh, just squeeze it here?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:下午刚看到
Alice: I just saw it this afternoon.
Alice:一次用三个吗
Alice: Do you use three at a time?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 我就用了一个两个吧
Tasha: I just used one or two.
Tasha: 我说我今天没有用过
Tasha: I said I haven't used it today.
Tasha: oh
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 有点多
Tasha: That's a bit much.
Tasha: 好你要用你的是吗
Tasha: Okay, do you want to use yours?
Tasha: 嗯这不差不多吗
Tasha: Hmm, isn't this pretty much the same?
Tasha: 啊都可以了
Tasha: Ah, it's all good now.
Tasha: 要找什么
Tasha: What are you looking for?
Jake: 笔
Jake: A pen.
Tasha: 让我给你拿支笔吧
Tasha: Let me get you a pen.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Alice:太长了
Alice: It's too long.
Alice:是吧太夸张
Alice: Right? It's so exaggerated.
Tasha: 哈哈夸张
Tasha: Haha, exaggerated.
Alice:这不夸张吗
Alice: Isn't it exaggerated?